the Army controlling the streets of Aya
culture
don't shoot a woman shouts
demonstrators in the Andean city were
contained by Security Forces but the
protest turned deadly
Health officials say at least seven
people were killed and more than 50
wounded as protesters tried to overrun
the local Airport
by the Army thousands of policemen were
deployed in the capital many
demonstrators marched peacefully others
clashed with police
[Music]
the human rights office asked for
security forces not to use deadly force
former president Pedro Castillo blamed
president Dina boluarte for the unrest
in a handwritten letter as he waited for
the verdict the judge overseeing
Castillo's case said he promoted The
public's disturbance of the peace and on
Thursday ordered Castillo to remain in
custody for 18 months for the crimes of
rebellion and conspiracy
some supporters blame Congress for his
demise
would have been a different story if
Congress had let him work but no the
only wanted to fill his post
now the lookout for most peruvians is
for everyone to leave
makers for change now come on
that Congress does not represent us it
has no legitimacy it has only five
percent approval how can they vacate a
president
[Music]
Presidente has declared a 30-day state
of emergency 15 regions are now under
curfew for five days
I call on Congress to make the best
decisions to shorten the deadlines and
make the necessary reforms we are all
living here
now many say the country is in the hands
of lawmakers the longer they take to
bring forward the elections the more
people will rise up against them